get a look at different line matchups throughout
the evening right now Conor Clifton on the back
end as Arizona changes Savers find a SE
right up the middle that puck bounce the
scores kyoso follows up on the play and buries
it and the Sabers take an early one to nothing
lead a little quick D to D clip and up the middle
right there to KY aosa the first shot by Robinson
the save it's up in the air and then KY aosa once
again just following in right place at the right
time and he Taps another one into the net right
there nice job there by Robinson though getting
in I'm not sure if he touched it up high there
or not doesn't matter face off's being dropped
they're moving on and that's a big goal for the
Sabers he takes a lot on his shoulders I'll tell
you that and he takes it personal every night
so these guys if they're willing to listen they
can learn quick shot Vela steers that one to the
side quick shot to the net leads to an opportunity
and the volume of shots you can put at the net
just keep putting parts to the net eventually
they start to go Skinner Thompson to Middle stat
middle stat looking for Skinner to the slotting
fires that one off the Poston right now that
one comes back up top and darene will spin it
to Yoki Haru between the legs of cousins who
gets it back in the slot shot with a rebound
it's clear to the boards visitors led by Nick
with five on the power play Keller with four
of them up top melli with a shot that's stopped
by Levi darene on the far side defending here's
coie in front what a save Deon Levi getting
used to that push off to the left hand side
as he covers that one up yeah Devon's doing a lot
better job here going post to post and keeping his
body up and making these saves You' seen at the
last few times he's played nice redir from the
and will skate to the middle of the ice as they
give it to him now ahead Dylan cousins puts that
one in behind Travis durman who then goes for a
spill against the wall Sabers get it to the side
of the net looking to put that one in front it
bounces up to the near faceof dot Arizona with
a puck in their own hand trying to Quick up melli
will drop it off and Moser will carry it into the
Buffalo Zone feeds it to the slot quick slot and a
great save made by Levi Murray standing his ground
just inside the line as Kellman tried
to move it out here's a walking shot
scores we've got ourselves a tie game as the
coyotes got buzzing a little bit there on the
Sabers and this is his first career goal just
three Sabers kind of tied up in a bad spot right
there you can't have so many guys right there
in a small area because look soon as a puck
pops out you're outnumbered heading in towards
the network Levi is Levi's out challenging we
see that puck do find the five hole he gets en
closed just a split second too late and then
puck in the back KB will racing it after it
deep in the zone against K just picked up his
first NHL gold pck comes back to the point
shot by Clifton there's a rebound Robinson
scores welcome to the neighborhood Eric Robins
and the saers take it two to one lead but
Krabs doing a nice job here on the foret
and he's going to want to do all the work
right here moves to poo Point there's the
quick shot by Clifton but a nice net front
Presence by Eric Robinson he told us in the
intermission to where he likes to go straight
ahead hockey simple hockey and that's exactly
right there he won the battle heble slide that
one underneath the goenda back up 2-1 here
1346 left in the second period down the left
side feeds it through for KBS Robinson parks
to the front of the net with a puck now on the
stick of kylo poso here's a shot scores Payton
cribs he wasted zero time in all three goals
in this game coming from that same line front
of himself it's going to be a second goal of
the year but good work once again by this line
KY post it down low just making that tight
little turn and finding crabs after a little
give and go but the big thing look in front
of the net you got 50 going to the front of
the net two guys have to come to him he went
direct through the net you see him and then
he pulls out and that just opens everything
up right there and pton crabs able to and now
Keller at Center Ice can't get around Victor
Rison as sends it ahead here's Murray to the
net backand off the create some Chaos on the
four check and doing gets it back he'll play
it ahead to Skinner feeds it through here's
Peta driving right down the middle and a pat
save puck back in front they score Fela made
the first stop but that puck comes back out
in front in a hurry and PKA picks it up to make
it four to one young man how fast he is and look
at just he get separation between both of them
there's the puck goes up in the air he throws
it to the of the net it goes under verela hits
his pad and looks like it bounces him there's
the first opportunity the saves made he gets
the puck throws it back to the front of the net
yeah it goes right between his legs and that left
pad is the what's going to poke it back in watch
right here as it's thrown to the front of the
net how about getting the park to the front of
the net things happen Levi saving a rebound he's
got it not sure where it is as he looks around
but Eric Robinson on his own down in the corner
doesn't mind handling the puck waiting for the
Savers to finish the change Robinson it FR and he
is stopped Point Blank by Vela what a feed as he
works with Dylan cousins on that one yeah he's on
a roll here tonight Princeton man right here the
crossword King every shift he's on the ice he's
trying to make something happen every time and
he creates that turnover pass right there with
his pressure and his Dylan cousins looking for
the payoff off the post Von in the battle behind
the net again look out Dylan cousins knock from
behind and it's going to Spring a breakaway chance
here for Zucker one-on-one with Levi he makes the
stop dein Levi he does he goes communicating with
the guys down in the corner too here's Zucker he's
going to get in behind and he's going to try to
go five hole looks like he's going to try to come
back through the lags here Fed Up the middle and
Yi Haru putting Chase on there I don't know if he
yeah he looks to go five hole there but it's okay
check on the internet the internet you believe
everything on the internet here's the pass ahead
cousins going to get a partial break and a save by
Vela no TR to better a pass now towards the
front of the neck valaki went to the front
of the goal Moser melli comes off the wall B
melli trying to find a lane and takes the shot
they score melli got it to the net and Carone
over at that far post just as Thompson got back
into the play it's a 4-2 Sabers lead now with
713 to go in the third period yeah kco is 14th
of the year he's team lead 14th goal see the
Sabers right here just a quick pass and leevi
he's out challenging but he right there he's
depending on his D on the back side to take
that over and you see 33 come across get going
meanwhile Thompson's playing back and forth here
getting it back in front oh good save by Fela
and Eric Robinson Racing after the puck on the
far wall but he's got some company there he's
trying to fight it free KBs in front looking
for Benson couldn't tip that one in there's
a shot off the far wall grasas dolene into
the empty net that's the one the Savers needed
they're fifth of the night they're up five to
two they needed to come to work and get the job
done tonight if they wanted to start moving the
direction they need to well let the horns
sound saber Str going home Happy 52 the
final